my director told us that our goal was to
create every phone call and every client
visit to turn that into a revenue
generating visit well if a woman comes
in and she's pregnant the only way we
can do that is by selling her an
abortion right because we don't do
prenatal care Planned Parenthood does
not provide prenatal care at any of
their clinics across the country they
don't do you know adoption services
don't make money off of that so the only
way we can make money was to sell women
an abortion and we were given the
directive to sell abortion I have this
next guest with us actually was a
recommendation by my wife who read this
lady's book unplanned you can find her
at Abby Johnson dot org knock on door
get it right Abby Johnson thank you for
being on the show thank you for having
me I'm very glad to have you on the show
and like I said okay so full disclosure
I never lie to people and be like I read
your book was I I've read excerpts but
my wife was enthralled and she was once
you have to have her on so you know
we've had we've had some pro-life people
on the show before and my wife knows all
of them she reads almost anything she
can get her hands on but there was
something here that really touched her
have you have you noticed a reaction
from many people who've read your book
that that sort of differentiates it I
guess from a lot of the other sort of
pro-life sites or books out there yeah I
think one of the things is that because
I used to be a pro-choice person you
know and then and then writing a book
kind of about being that person and
being in the pro-choice movement you
know my purpose was not to vilify them
but just to help people have an
understanding of where they're coming
from
not saying that it's right abortion is
absolutely wrong but that you know we're
not at war with these people that are
working in the clinics or these people
who are pro-choice we're at war with the
ideology but not the people themselves
and so I think that was something that
was new to the pro-life movement
honestly because they had for so long
wanted
to make enemies of the people who do
support abortion right I think you're
right and I think we've talked about
this I think there's a time for that I
think there's a time to throw caution to
the wind and offend people and it's okay
because you're offending the right
people and I think there are people who
are not beyond reaching and you need to
understand the difference and that's
really sort of the skill I guess of
expressing political ideology is knowing
how to walk that line in a way that's
appropriate for your audience so you
worked you worked at now was it it was
Planned Parenthood right it wasn't just
any abortion clinic that's right right
it was Planned Parenthood clinic I was
the director there we were an abortion
facility I was there for eight years now
you say that you were an abortion
facility does that mean that that was
your designated purpose at this Planned
Parenthood facility because we're told
that you know it's a very small
percentage of what Planned Parenthood
actually does yeah you know you don't
agree I can tell you no it was we were
there too
it's kind of a tricky question because
we were there as a family planning
clinic who provided abortions okay but
the whole premise behind being a family
planning clinic is to get women on a
contraceptive method that will
eventually fail them we know that 54% of
women having abortions we're using
contraception at the time they got
pregnant so the whole purpose is get
them on a contraceptive method that will
fail them so that we can make them
abortion patients so we're willing to be
lost leaders if you will in the
contraceptive movement because we will
eventually sell them our big-ticket item
which is abortion now you say that I
want to be clear because I'm not
necessarily against all contraception I
don't know where you end up now you say
there you were actually encouraged to
give them the less effective
contraceptive available or do demeans
it's just mean contraception in general
well we want to give we want to give
them a contraceptive method that has a
higher risk of failure real right so
human so and what's gonna have a higher
risk of failure those that have higher
human error failure rates right so birth
control pill I'm 35 years old I can't
remember to take a pill at the
same time every day right a 14-year old
sure as heck is not gonna remember to
take a pill at the same time every day
so that it's 99% effective right so put
her on a pill that she's probably not
gonna take at the same time every day
that she's not gonna know how to
properly take eventually she will get
pregnant and then she will be one of our
clients that makes us now quick question
because you're going to have critics
here was that actually outlined to you
as an employee at Planned Parenthood or
was it just sort of an unwritten well we
know that this contraception will
eventually fail them or do they say
listen our goal is to get them on the
big Hawk for abortion yeah well we had
an abortion quota that I've actually
exposed because I have the document that
showed where the the quota was on our
budget sheet so we had a quota for
abortion so we were to sell abortion to
women when they came in over 90% of
pregnant women who enter Planned
Parenthood will have an abortion so what
was that number over 90 percent over 90
percent of women who walk in through the
doors will have an apartment
pregnant women pregnant woman yeah so
the idea that they're there to offer
options or referrals for other services
it's just a farce because my director
told us that our goal was to create
every phone call and every client visit
to turn that into a revenue generating
visit well if a woman comes in and she's
pregnant the only way we can do that is
by selling her an abortion right because
we don't do prenatal care Planned
Parenthood does not provide prenatal
care at any of their clinics across the
country they don't do you know adoption
services don't make money off of that so
the only way we could make money was to
sell women an abortion and we were given
the directive to sell abortion so it's
the Glengarry Glen Ross of dead babies
ABC always be closing that was given
from the top down not to make not to
make abortion jokes but we have to
actually do otherwise I get horribly
uncomfortable serious topic yeah yeah
you know you knew what you were gonna
get that's exactly it
you know and I talked about that with
Planned Parenthood there web
cite the highest quality health services
at the lowest possible prices this is
the first video I ever did that went you
know semi viral I think of a time it
maybe got thirty thousand plays and we
did crazy Pete's abortion barn and it
was Planned Parenthood's a dirty
used-car salesman because I thought back
then not knowing what you're saying now
that it just seemed like scummy greasy
dirty car salesmen and you're telling
you that behind the scenes that was the
goal
abortion quotas and it sounds terrible
and people how are you making what using
humor is not making light of a situation
it's shining a light on the situation I
mean how else do you abortion quotas
it's it's so laughable it's horrifying I
can't believe that they actually gave
that to you at the directive okay we'll
come back here from this break because I
want to talk about your turning point
and that's what my wife and I talked
about for a long time allotted with
Crider Abby Johnson dot org stay tuned
back with Abby Johnson Abby Johnson comm
of the book unplanned listen my wife
loves this book and she talked about
something Abby you know to get a little
serious here she talks about your
turning point I don't want to give
anything away for the listener but you
pinpointed it to a very specific moment
which I thought was was pretty impactful
you want to talk about that yeah so
after working there for eight years I
mean I was the director so I wasn't you
know in the room very often for medical
procedures or anything like that
we had a visiting physician come in from
out of town who was performing abortions
at my facility abortion Planned
Parenthood's protocol in the National
Abortion Federation their protocol for
abortion is that it be done in a blind
manner so they have a suction tube
that's hooked up to the Machine and they
just blindly poke around inside the
woman's uterus until they think they
have enough tissue in a jar so that was
the way that I knew abortion to be
performed day in and day out but this
doctor actually used an ultrasound at
his own practice during the abortion so
that he could see what was taking place
inside the woman's womb because
shockingly enough it is safer if they
are
can't see what he's doing while he's
performing surgery great so but that was
I don't know that I agree with the
premise but continue that was something
I never really thought about before so
he said that you know it's time
permitted that I he would have me come
in so I could assist my job during the
abortion was to hold the ultrasound
probe on the woman's abdomen so that he
could see what was going on during the
abortion and I watched a 13 week old
baby fight and struggle for his life
during that abortion procedure and I
knew then that I had been lied to
I knew that because of that I had in
turn lied to thousands of women who had
come through my facility is tomato I
helped to provide about 20,000 abortions
during my time with Planned Parenthood
so I knew I had to get out I knew I had
to leave and that was when I made the
decision to quit how soon did that occur
after that moment with the ultrasound I
lasted out a week later
okay so what sometimes people would go
back and they'd go oh I had my sort of
come-to-jesus moment you realize what
didn't really happened so this was
literally within the week you were gone
yeah and I I didn't want to leave my job
because I made a ton of money everything
here and all my friends were there so I
didn't want to leave I was trying really
hard to make it okay
in my mind you know what I had seen but
after a week I was just like I can't I
can't do it I can't make this right in
my mind are you still friends with any
of them no no no they testified against
me in court actually so we don't really
talk anymore yeah that can kind of put a
damper on the whole class now how did
what did they how did they testify
against you
what was it well three weeks after I
left Planned Parenthood they took me to
court and they were concerned that I was
going to share proprietary information
about the organization which that was a
reasonable concern for them yeah let's
be honest here let's be honest yeah that
was a good
surd but uh you know you can't sue
somebody for becoming pro-life and I had
never signed any sort of confidentiality
statement while working there so they
lost and that's it what well even then
though it would seem in most cases and
you can tell me I'm out of line here
friends people who are your friends you
develop these strong relationships
generally speaking if it comes down to
siding with the corporation or a an
organization or a friend they would side
with the friend so what do you think was
such a strong poll but they decided to
support Planned Parenthood the
organization to come against you a be
the person in court yeah I think money I
think they were concerned about losing
their job they were higher level
employees with Planned Parenthood so I
think that was certainly a concern I
mean they didn't know that this would
happen but after they testified against
me
they actually got fired so you know it
might have been different if they would
have been able to see ahead to that but
why would I I don't know they were
crappy witnesses I guess so yeah that's
a weird reason to be fired but I'm glad
they were I'm not I'm not contesting it
but that's the reason to be fired no no
no no I know I mean I was glad I'm glad
that they were fired but the problem is
it just gets replaced so let me ask you
this when you see you know I've talked
about this with my producer actually
who's not here right now fund F who is
liberal socially but incredibly pro-life
when you see the political football
being played with the issue of abortion
and Planned Parenthood comes in the news
I mean right the defense is always from
the left no no no no no no it's not
about abortions they provide health care
to millions of women in this country who
otherwise never be able to afford it the
right is just this is their anti-woman
sexist crusade what do you think when
you hear that you know Planned
Parenthood does not provide any services
in regard to women's health care that
low-income women cannot get from any
other federally qualified health center
rural public health book
Center hospital system or Medicaid
provider in their City there is not one
place where Planned Parenthood is
located where there are not multiple
other options for her to get health care
if she's low-income and bleed or not
Planned Parenthood is not always that
inexpensive I mean sometimes women are
having to pay anywhere from 50 to 175
dollars for you know to get an annual
exam with Planned Parenthood sometimes
not but sometimes they do
how much have an abortion cost in
comparison but it starts at about $400
okay so even the abortions aren't
necessarily inexpensive no what-ifs we
can't afford it we would give them tips
on how to raise money for their abortion
okay so it's not like an emergency room
where you have to serve them anyway and
then no no no no you have to pay in fact
if a woman came in they're not even
altruistic and their abortion providing
it still comes down to the dollars they
we would this is like really heinous but
this is true when a woman would come in
we would take her payment based on her
last cycle so we would say okay you're
you know we think based on your life
cycle you're eight weeks and five days
pregnant right well if we got them back
to the room for their abortion and we
did the ultrasound and we find that they
were actually let's say ten days ten
weeks and one day pregnant well there's
a price difference between eight weeks
and ten weeks $100 price difference so
somebody usually the last person hired
would be tasked to go into the room
while the woman's on the table and say
hey um you're a little bit further along
than what we thought you were so we're
going to need to collect a hundred extra
dollars before we can start your
abortion procedure and then we would be
like is it down in your purse do you
want me to grab it for you or does your
boyfriend have it out front or how do
you want to take care of that I've been
hustled in the streets of New York more
politely yeah literally for a bag of
M&Ms I'm not joking that's a true story
it cost $2 for a package I ended up
losing $20 but I had five bags of M&Ms
so I guess
okay my cousins never let me forget it
that is unbelievable
so okay so it's again Glengarry Glen
Ross it's all about the upsell right
it's like do you want the large popcorn
hundred dollars for your abortion where
do you line up politically for those
listening were you were you to the left
before and did you shift your whole
political ideology or just in the life
issue you know I am
I was definitely as left as left could
be when I worked at Planned Parenthood
it was funny when when I first started
getting calls about doing media
interviews and you know I got a call to
go on Bill O'Reilly's show and I called
my parents who are very conservative and
I was like oh my gosh I'm gonna go on
Fox News and my mom was like you hate
Fox News but I was like yeah I think
maybe I'm gonna start watching it now
but you know it was I mean it wasn't a
lot of things changed in my life so you
know I'm probably too liberal for most
conservatives I'm too conservative for
most liberals I follow a consistent life
ethic so I'm against the death penalty
against abortion against assisted
suicide so kind of has me fall in the
middle okay that makes sense so then you
would have a better perspective as
someone who is pro-life I do say this
though since you're pro-life would you
agree with me I say listen they're
open-ended issues there are closed-ended
issues I could vote for a Democrat in a
local election because there are
pro-life democrats in a local election
who don't you know they don't have the
control to increase the size of the
federal government you know and and and
local municipalities have the right to
do public schools that's what then
they're right um but I do think that if
you are pro-life if you believe that is
a life it precludes you from supporting
the Democrat platform in a national
election am I out of line no I think
you're absolutely right because I mean
you're right the state state local
elections I mean I have you know I have
proto I have pro-life democrat friends
who I'd happily vote for but when it
comes to you know a federal election
national election
I hate it you know I wish it wasn't that
way I wish it wasn't such a party issue
but no I mean you've got a you know the
Democratic Party who's trying to take
God out of their platform who is trying
to make abortion one of the top you know
issues in their platform I mean how can
you women's health careful with your
language now right where I I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry
don't make me be sexist and corrects
your self-loathing woman miss now we
have a new Washington DC there's these
clinics called care of them and they are
oh and for them the abortion spot yeah
absolutely
yeah I know they like working I'm person
yeah we do that there's right ID behind
that let's show the disgusting broads
drinking tea talking about their uterus
yeah which by the way I don't really
want to talk about uterus is even if it
is non abortion related I think that
makes me sexist but just a personal
opinion I don't I think it's fair I
don't I don't that is fair that is fair
but I do think I'm entitled to an
opinion for example I'm sure you have
very impassioned opinions on scrotums
okay well that's okay you don't have to
but it's your right well that's one that
it really bothers me right now uterus
now opinion it's not about your uterus
it's about that life it's about that
baby and this is one thing where they
get well Republican side I tell you what
you can deal with your body in no other
instance none do does a Republican
Republican party platform you might have
some individuals you know I think Morris
and your feet or something like that but
no actual Republican platform has an
interest in a lady's body in any other
facet aside from one has to do with that
life they don't want to have an opinion
on whether you can buy contraception
whether you can shave your legs whether
you can work at none of it
shouldn't that show people that it's not
really about taking the Republican Party
is not really interested in what you're
doing with your body we're more
interested in what you're doing with the
body of the
person that's in your womb that's what
we're interested in you do whatever you
want to with your body you can go pierce
it up you can get a bunch of tattoos do
whatever you want but does Planned
Parenthood do piercings everybody don't
answer that we have to go to a break but
I'll bring you right back happy Johnson
Abby Johnson comm stay tuned back with
Abby Johnson I'm surprised she stayed
after all of that nether region talk
beforehand but you have to talk about it
when you're dealing with abortion I mean
feminists are so ugly in their language
right now and the truth is you have
people out there like Patricia Heaton
you have people who are genuinely strong
women who support women in in selling
their them their personalities in
putting on display their talents and
their skills as opposed to their body
and there really is a tie-in between the
the abortion issue and what we sort of
call third wave feminism have you
noticed now I guess sort of being more
middle-of-the-road the pushback on this
authoritarian feminism that you see from
people at Planned Parenthood and Cara
Pham those kinds of campaigns yeah I
think so I mean I think we're seeing a
lot you know kind of this idea of like
new feminism we're seeing a push in that
and that's that's really exciting
actually I mean I have some friends that
are pro-choice writers and you know
they're they have told me you know Abby
if there's one thing that's going to
flip this abortion movement on its head
it's going to be when when when women
really embrace this idea of new feminism
that you know women don't have to choose
between being a mom and having a career
right we can have both and that we're
not just breeders that we have more to
contribute to society than just our
ability to have children you know which
is amazing but we're not just tell you
I'll tell you something men don't think
of you that way at all particularly the
pro-life men who tend to respect women
much more listen a pro-life man doesn't
get to check out and say sorry
sweetheart go gavotte suck down a tube
they have to assume responsibility for
that woman so just I'm just saying it
not to derail the conversation but I
have tons of guy friends never once to
the conversation go hey now that the
women are wrong they're gone aren't you
just
glad that we have a bunch of walking
uterus is waiting on us hand and foot to
make Sam it never comes up so you know
and there's been I think there's been
actually just like there's been more
racial division this country there's
been more gender sexual division I think
than ever because there's a rejection of
this from this supposed men's rights
activists which are kind of silly too
and this third wave feminism and it
sounds like you maybe even some
pro-choice friends that you have are
somewhere in the middle where you can
find reason yeah and I think they're I
think they're they hate it honestly they
hate that this idea of new feminism
makes sense this pro-life feminism they
hate that that makes sense to them
because it completely goes against the
traditional feminist model right that
there is no equality between the sexes
that you know women should be ahead of
men that it's not about equality there's
this us versus them but if you're a head
of men then we have rape culture and
that's a whole other problem so we have
another thing right you know yeah we
need to figure out where exactly we need
to be in the line to just avoid the rape
culture and the the retroactive non
consent is a big issue right right I
want to see this now are you familiar
with I'm sure and McIlhenny in the
Gosnell movie that's been doing so we
had her on the show and she talked about
the horror stories of Gosnell now she
contends that obviously he's terrible
and they're doing a movie on it because
it was a national story but that it's
not that far off from what's probably
happening at some other abortion clinics
across this country what do you know
we're not talking about the sanitary
conditions but how far along the trail
they actually do abortions how it's just
a chop shop boom in and out how much in
common do you think someone like Gosnell
would share with the general american
abortion doctor maybe a Planned
Parenthood you know I don't think a
whole lot honestly I mean yes I think
Gosnell was I do think that he was a
rare sort of he was running a sort of
rare kind of operation there are others
like him
we know that Douglas Karpin in Houston
who's no longer practicing as an
abortionist you know we know that he was
doing the
same sorts of things we know that
Pendergrass is doing those sorts of
things car heart you know these it's
these later term abortionist those that
are willing to do abortions into the
third trimester because let's be honest
me if you're willing to do abortions
into the third trimester you're probably
kind of shaky on morality in the first
place people like Elizabeth Warren yeah
well yeah but I think a lot of people
even pro-choicers I know were just
appalled by what they saw in the Gosnell
trial and um you know I've talked to
people who were actually there who are
pro-choice writers who said you know
what hearing about what took place
inside of the clinic that made me really
question what's going on in you know
made me question the humanity of the
unborn child which is good well I think
that's an interesting point there so let
me ask you I just Elizabeth Warren Jared
you remember the name of the other gosh
the Texas Wendy Davis sorry they're
almost interchangeable in my mind is
just sort of the anti baby cackling
witches and I mean which is I don't mean
the other word I mean which is cackling
which is take it in context who believe
in abortion pretty much on demand free I
mean you saw the tussle with Rand Paul
and Elizabeth Warren so you say a lot of
you're pro-choice writers or a lot of
pro-choice people in the country we're
appalled at that but you didn't see the
outrage from from HuffPo from liberal
websites and you don't see the outrage
in third trimester abortion from
Democrat politicians so do you think
that that's an issue where the elite are
so much further along the trail that
people the general pro-choice person in
this country can be reached still
effectively
yeah so here's the thing so anybody
that's in leadership inside the
pro-choice movement they cannot deviate
from abortion on demand without apology
right they cannot you cannot start
saying well okay I think abortions okay
here until 24 weeks or I believe
abortion is okay if it's done this way
but not that way right because then you
pro lifers can really easily start to
pick apart your
argument so for them for people who are
really leading discharge I mean this was
how it was for me at Planned Parenthood
I mean you cannot deviate from the plan
of legal abortion anywhere at all times
without exception through all nine
months of pregnancy it's a good point so
you're saying even if those people in
leadership may agree with those points
that hey come on you're talking about a
third trimester abortion they would
behind closed doors you think say yeah I
agree but they publicly cannot deviate
from the gameplan
yeah they cannot I mean I remember when
I worked at Planned Parenthood just
thinking okay abortions after 24 weeks
that seems too far you know these babies
are they can survive out of the womb
they're viable oh you're saying after
four weeks oh we're not even close to
the third trimester at that point how
often are abortions performed after four
weeks and planned pain or not third
trimester but you know four or five six
week abortions well so most abortions
are performed before twelve weeks right
so there's in the first trimester so the
overwhelming majority of abortions are
performed in the first trimester so I
was in first month my apologies you know
I was going so then you know then
there's a you know a drop into second
trimester abortions and then there's an
even more significant drop into third
trimester abortions so you know you're
looking at maybe you know we think maybe
about 20,000 babies are aborted in the
third trimester in the United States
every year that's still shocking it's a
lot yeah I know it's a lot I mean that's
that's a point where there's really no
scientific debate as to whether it's
potentially viable as to whether it's an
individual as to whether they have nerve
endings there's no scientific debate at
that point so here's my point so and
I've always said this I think that with
abortion you know sort of the Oprah
soundbite is it's ultimately sacrifice
at the altar of self it's personal
convenience personal happiness is more
important in this life and I feel like
and I think you've reiterated doubt I
want to make sure I don't misrepresent
you there are people in the movement
we're at a point where it's not about
women's rights they do believe it's a
life especially as science comes in
they know it's a life they don't care
anyway is that unfair no that's totally
fair
I mean why I remember a pro-lifer asking
me one time you know when do you think
life begins and I remember my answers
being like what doesn't matter it
doesn't matter when life begins because
abortion is legal and I'm gonna do
everything I can to support legal
abortion through all nine months of
pregnancy that is not how I felt
that's not actually what I felt in my
heart that's not how I felt my mind but
I could not stray from that talking
point why were you why did you go into
this why did you feel passionately
enough about about this to do it you
know I've had two abortions myself so
about 70% of people that work in the
abortion industry have had abortions so
I think a lot of it is just kind of
justifying your own past behavior or
your own past mistakes but I mean
honestly I was just very naive I was a
college student I didn't know anything
about Planned Parenthood and you know
when this woman is telling me how they
serve these you know uninsured or
underinsured women and they're the only
hope for these women if they need health
care I mean it just sounds really it
sounds like Planned Parenthood is this
benefactor to the masses and that was
something that I was interested in
helping with okay so your heart was in
the right place maybe the mind took a
little while to catch up
it's very misguided mm-hmm that makes
sense and I think there are a lot of
people out there like you and like I
said I think there are people the
Elizabeth Warren's
I just forgot her name again I just
forgot a name detective Wendy Davis gosh
I could never remember it you know why
it's like a generic white lady name
right yeah yeah I guess it's anti-white
racism it's Wendy Davis racist yes
exactly against white women so those
people are beyond reaching you can have
to make an example of them but there are
people like you out there who are maybe
not quite far along far enough along the
trail and I do think Abby Johnson's book
unplanned is a great way to start Abby
Johnson org unplanned much like our
private part discussions in this
interview Abby thank you so much for
being with us so sorry did I miss
anything any closing words here that I
don't that I missed Oh
just so you know you're talking about
conversion you know and how we can
convert minds I actually run an
organization that reaches out to
abortion clinic workers and helps them
come over to the pro-life side and we've
had 160 workers come to us so there are
a lot of people who are working in these
clinics who want to leave who are
looking for an excuse to leave and they
just need a hand they just need a hand
up so that they can get out and that's
we've been able to provide and 160 of
those workers were six of them were
abortionist that are now no longer
performing abortions so it can happen
okay well thank you Abby but you must go
peddle your anti woman's sexist
propaganda elsewhere Abby Johnson org
you must go thanks for being with a stay
tuned to ladder with crowd or more after
we keep the lights on with these
sponsors congratulations you stumbled
into the dark corner of the internet
that wasn't plastered with breasts and
you can subscribe by clicking my face or
watching one of these videos next to me
do they